[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle cuisine alimentation agriculture
mais aussi politique et cette semaine
nous recevons Emmanuel taché de la
Pagerie bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et avec moi pour
présenter cette émission Jean-Pierre
Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigit bonjour Emmanuel Tachet
d'apagerie alors vous êtes député
rassemblement national des bouches du
Rône élu depuis juin 2022 vous êtes
entré au rassemblement national 10 ans
plus tôt en 2012 mais votre carrière
politique commence dès 95 sous les
couleurs du RPR puis de l'UMP vous avez
alors 20 ans d'abord assistant
parlementaire vous devenez conseiller
politique de palzo jusqu'en 2001 vous
êtes aussi l'un des fondateurs de
l'association de défense des droits LGBT
glib entre 2018 et 2021 vous êtes chargé
de la communication au groupe des
eurodéputés RN au Parlement européen
ardent défenseur de la corriida dans un
excellent magazine de la rédaction
d'elcp vous allez au bout de vos
convictions on le retrouve dans le menu
du jour ah oui et ça dépotte de la
gardiane autrement dit de la daube de
taureau et en dessert un tiram Missou
dans le dessous des plats en janvier la
star c'est la galette on vous offre la
dégustation il y en aura pour tous les
goûts dans les pieds dans le plat les
Français de plus en plus fans de riz et
dans l'assiette il n'y a pas que du
basmati mais aussi du grain français
cultivé en Camargue reportage à suivre
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
[Musique]
Emmanuel taché de la Pagerie quel
parcours pour vous l'enfant du 93 avec
votre silhouette un Brigitte un fit de
toriador vous avez réussi à vous faire
une place au soleil d'Arles ville de
ferriia où tout naturellement vous avez
donc pris le taureau par les cornes pour
défendre la Carida au nom des traditions
culturelles si on connaît tous la
stratégie alimentaire de l'Europe
baptisée de la fourche à la fourchette
la vôtre pourrait s'intituler de la
banderille à l'assiette et oui c'est
solide taureau victime de mise à mort
insupportable anachronique pour les
anticorridas vous les défendez quoi
qu'il en coûte et à ce titre làà votre
plat du jour n'est pas innocent une
gardiane de taureau une viande mijotée
dans une sauce au vin rouge comme une
cape une façon de nous dire que ces
pauvres bêtes ne sont pas mortes pour
rien mais pour la patrie et la défense
d'un terroir la Camargue ici nous ne
sommes pas avec Brigitte des talibans
antiiande donc nous allons sans doute
nous régaler de cette daube aux accents
provençau mais dites-moi franchement la
viande d'un taureau excité stressé mort
dans le sang et la poussière a-t-elle
pour vous plus de sens et de goût que
celle d'un taureau tout simplement sorti
d'un abattoir alors d'abord je tiens a
salué le travail des éleveurs de taureau
qui ont permis à ce que la viande de de
taureau euh est la première àop de
viande bovvine en France ça c'est le
fruit d'un long travail je crois que
c'est en 1996 si je ne dis pas de de
sottise euh et le taureau camarg en fait
euh n'existe et toutes ces exploitations
extensives n'existent que si j'allais
dire la finitude et euh et la corida euh
ces taureaux ne sont pas victimes ils
vivent entre 5 et 7 ans euh en camarg
euh sur 1 à 1,5 hectares par par animal
font l'objet de tous les soins de la
part de nos manadiers qui les chérissent
il faut savoir que chez nous le le
taureau ce n'est pas une bête qu'on
envoie à l'abattoir c'est une bête qu'on
envoie au combat il y a quelque chose de
de sacré dans le rapport entre l'homme
et le taureau et et chez nous pas qu'il
y a plus de souffrance en corida que à
l'abattoir je ne parlerai pas de
souffrance parce que je me garderai anim
je me garderai de faire de
l'anthropomorphisme euh les notoréros
respectent les animaux bien évidemment
euh les lois de la corrid ont changé les
chevaux sont aussi carapaonnés et
protégés je comprends hein qu'on est
mort finalement il mort ilinitud c'est
quand même tout le débat sur les anti il
peutêtre gracié il peut-être gracié mais
ce qu' m'en ce qui m'ennuie moi dans le
dans le combat que j'ai mené pour le
maintien de la corriida et la défense de
la corriidda ça a été j'allais dire
l'excès la méconnaissance de nos euh de
notre culture la la méconnaissance de
notre aussi fait agricole parce qu'il y
a un vrai fait agricole et économique
autour de cela euh et puis moi je crois
profondément que la France est un pays
de liberté
euh je crois qu'il faut qu'on soit
capable de défendre nos particularismes
et moi ce que j'ai entendu ça peut
paraître simpliste mais je crois que ça
résume tout l'amour aussi de euh du
peuple et des gens que j'ai le j'ai le
privilège de servir c'est laissez-nous
tranquilles euh on ne fait de mal à
personne on ne fait que servir nos
traditions moi je vois plein dans il
disent que vous fait du mal au du mal
aux animaux oui mais moi je vois des
enfants et notamment des des petits dans
des amours reculés euh de la ville
d'Arle qui est la ville principale de ma
circonscription je vois aussi beaucoup
de jeunes qu'on dit je n'aime pas cette
expression des quartiers euh qui s'en
sortent grâce à la course camarguaise
grâce aux écoles taorines en étant en
contact des taoreros de leurs
professeurs des taureaux euh et et tout
cela fait un peuple une nation locale
qui vous savez nous on a été épargné
heureusement pendant les émeutes qui se
sont passées sur l'entièreté de mon
territoire il n'y a eu aucun effet rien
et je crois que je
l au cultur écoutez moi le soir le soir
on m'a appelé pour me dire monsieur le
député ne vous rendez pas là où là où on
était au pic des émeutes ne vous rendez
pas en circonscription voilà c'était les
ordres qu'on qu'on recevait rentrer chez
vous et je me suis aperçu que c'était le
soir de la pégolade à Arles où il y a eu
le pic de des émeutes et il y a eu des
tentatives de certains groupuscules et
je crois que de voir 3000 harlaésiens en
costume de voir les chevaux qui étaient
présents de voir nos taureaux avec nos
manadiers je crois pas que ce soit
quelque chose qui dissuade mais je crois
que il y a sur mon territoire un réel
respect des uns envers les autres et et
je crois que la corida aussi la culture
Torine oui mais participe du fait que
chaque partie de la population et quelle
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs et d'où qu'ell
viennent a un profond respect pour nos
traditions qui sont fortement ancré et
qui sont vécus il y a pas une semaine où
il se passe pas quelque chose soit
autour du du
costumelaisienne soit autour de nos
taureaux soit autour des chevaux enfin
c'est un territoire qui est extrêmement
ancré que ce soit de
Tarascon le choix de ce plat
vous nousiit le plaisir
nousous en apporter et on vous en
remercie alors cette gardienne de
taureau est-ce qu'elle ressemble à celle
que vous avez l'habitude de
manger écoutez moi c'est la première
fois que je mange du taureau alors on va
pas vous faire changer d'avis sur La
coridda mais on peut s'accorder pour
dire que le taureau je sais pas si
celui-ci vient d'une corida sans doute
non c'est très bon Brig c'est très
parfumé alorss parfumé la viande est un
petit peu un petit peu plus dure
peut-être que il y a moins de tendreté
peut-être que dans oui la viande est
puissante dans le mais la viande est un
peu puissante mais ça sent bien le vin
rouge et alors pour la la précision pour
ceux qui seraient intéressés c'est un
peu compliqué de trouver de la gardiane
alors moi je l'ai trouvé et la maison
s'appelle Marius c'est l'épicerie
inspirée il vendent ça sous forme de
Boco vous pouvez les trouver sur leur
site internet il vous les expédie ça de
façon très sécurisée et vraiment cette
gardienne d'aut vaut le détour he je
sais pas que vous pou comment écoutez
elle est elle est très bonne et je suis
étonné et agréablement surpris que vous
AZ pu vous en procurer oui oui
Jean-Pierre a été 400 coups
effectivement pour parce que visiblement
ça pas été un simple exercice à Paris
c'est difficile il y a peu de
restaurants même les restaurants
provençaux ne font pas de la gardien
peut-être que et elle a été elle a été
cuisinée comme vous l'avez précisé avec
du taureau AOP donc et du vin aussi si
on dit que c'est ça ressemble au bœuf
bourguignon ou que c'est une daube c'est
euh c'est ça ou c'est oui c'est sur le
même principeou c'est pas critique par
rapport à la à la recette g du tout
alors moi jeis pas critique sur le Bur
bourguignon parce que je suis à moitié
bourguignon et que c'est l'un des plats
que je réussis le mieux noni c'est le
même principe de de viande longement
mijoté alors après la typicité elle est
sur les sur les épices utilisées sur le
vin local ou non utilisé euh et sur mais
le mode de cuisson par j'ai TR pe chos à
vous dire sur la gardian Brig alors TR
chos savoir du coup jeanre alors save
pourquoi s'appelle gardian dites-moi oui
ben parce que elle doit son nom au
gardian le gardien des troupeaux de
taureaux élevés en semiliberté ce qu'on
appelle les malades hein je parle sous
le contrôle du député du Sud alors oui
le député des bouches du rô que je suis
vous direz qu'on dit gardien gardien
alors donc son nom gardien pardon et
l'émanade et la fleur naturelle et sa
principale nourriture ce qui donne à
cette viande une saveur unique et
parfumée la viande de taureau et vous
l'avez remarqué tendre goûteuse
légèrement plus forte que le bœuf tendre
oui moins tendre queun bœuf peut-être
mais elle est moins puissante qu'un
gibier et choisissez bien un taureau AOP
et plutôt un morcer un morceau comme le
collier ou la joue pour faire cette
daube et pour réussir une gardiane il
faut faire mariner la veille la viande
dans un mélange de vin rouge alors ça
vous saurez le choisir vous Brigit de
vinaigre avec du thint du romarin du
laurier des écorces d'orange sel poivre
oignons carotte on égoûte les morceaux
de viande on les fait frire et ensuite
on rajoute la marinade et on fait cuire
très longtemps au four et on rajoute
aussiu dou j'imagine oui très long ça
doit mijeter très longtemps 2h 3h et on
rajoute pas dans cette recette j'ai
regardé la recette mais on rajoute
parfois de l'ail et des enchois c'est
vrai oui mais alors après ça dépend de
là où vous êtes sur ce vaste territoire
de camarg et je crois qu'il y a à peu
près pas autant de recettes de gardien
qu'il y a de famille mais après chacun
la commande en fonction de sa proximité
avec le littoral par exemple et alors
vous votre recette à vous votre petit
truc pour réussir la gardiene c'est quoi
moi mon petit truc pour réussir la
gardien alors je vais peut-être me faire
arracher les yeux par rapport au au
citoyens de ma circonscription c'est que
je fais comme dans le buf Vignon je
rajoute un carré de chocolat ah oui
c'était vrai que c'est un petit un
petite astuce pas une révolution mais ça
permet de d'ajouter un peu de de liant
et Ste d'amertum mettez aussi beaucoup
de teint de laurier je trouve que c'est
assz Pr sent bien moi j'ai chance leses
sont très présentes j'ai la chance de
vivre dans un dans un dans un village ou
lors de mes promenades pour aller glaner
du bois lorsque j'ai le temps je n'ai
qu'à me baisser pour pour ramasser du
romarin du thint dans dans la colline
donc c'est assez commode et j'en mets
énormément oui aussi et alors vous vous
aimez vous retrouver derrière les
fourneaux c'est c'est une passion pour
vous de cuisiner c'est pas une passion
c'est un plaisir en fait c'est souvent
dit he j'enfonce une porte mais cuisin
c'est démontrer aux autres soit qu'on
les respecte soit qu'on les aime et moi
ça me fait toujours plaisir de me mettre
trop rarement au fourneau mais j'aime
énormément ça alors après j'ai un
problème moi ce sont les quantités
c'està c'estd que si on est quatre les
gens ça pensent qu'on va être 10 à table
quoi ah vous vous cuisinez en très très
grande quantité énormément mais ça doit
êre des souvenf FAM nomuse peut-être ou
ça doit être des souvenir des souvenirs
d'enfance d'une d'une grand-mère
piednoire oranaise généreuse qui partait
du principe que on se régalait
d'ailleurs elle le disait tu te régal
mon fils et on se reprenait une louche
dans l'assiette ce qui fait que
généralement quand on revenait des
vacances d'été ou autre
ouais moi j'avais tendance à être un peu
bouboule lorsque j'étais jeune et je
revenais encore un peu plus rondouillard
alors si c'est de la Doe C'est pas le
problème parce que ça c'est très bon
aussi une fois réchauffé deux ou TR
jours après donc si on fait de la DO
pour 10 qu on est quatre c'est pas un
vrai problème pour d'autres plat c'est
plus compliqué c'est le même principe
que beaucoup de recettes de famille qui
sont faites pour
être VO
çaessirime beaucoup cuisiner la dabe
provençal parce que j'adore le le goût
de l'olive pas forcément taureau le bœuf
oui le bœuf le taureau ça m'arrive
j'aime faire la blanquette après j'aime
faire des recettes qui sont un peu plus
typiques j'allais dire mais ça c'est mon
éducation du côté du côté de maman
j'aime beaucoup faire les tajines faire
ce qu'on appelle la coca faire la frita
aussi alors ça c'est tout des des des
recettes qui sont d'inspiration
espagnole mais qui sont né en Algérie
voilà j'aime beaucoup mais j'ai pas j'ai
peu de temps pour pour cuisiner je crois
que la dernière fois c'était pour les
fêtes de Noël avec avec la famille ça va
et le sud vous a inspiré le Sud où vous
êtes maintenant à les Panis par exemple
vous cuisinez ça
jà un petit peu j'étais déjà un petit
peu j'allais dire conditionné par cette
cuisine méditerranéenne qui était pas
une découverte pour moi euh tout n'est
pas découverte tout le temps mais oui ça
m' ça m'inspire par exemple je j'aime
maintenant faire des choses qui sont un
peu plus typiques un peu plus typiqu de
la région harlaisienne je m'y pique je
me suis acheté un un livre bah tiens la
semaine dernière un petit livret sur la
cuisine camargaise où je découvre des
recettes vous aimez bien aussi essayer
de nouvelles recettes tenter un petit
peu ou ouais en fait j'aime bien acheter
des petits livrets et tenter enfin
sortir de ma zone de confort qui sont
les les plats FAM à par la DO de taureau
c'est quoi bah vous avez les tines par
exemple ah c'est délicieux ça l'INE ou
c'est euh c'est c'est très très bon
dites aux auditeurs aux téléspectateurs
parce que tout le monde ne connaît pas
c'est une partie ce sont des petits
coquillages tout petits qui sont faits
généralement en persillade et voilà
qu'on qu'on mange qu'on mange un petit
peu avec très très local Paris avec un
peu de persil un peu d'ail et j'allais
vous demander parce que vous nous aviez
parlé que de plat avec de la viande vous
aimez aussi le poisson parce que vous
êtes effectivement tout près aussi de la
mer vous faites des des poissons grillés
vous le cuisinez alors moi j'aime bien
faire les Rouger en âge h alors c'est
quoi ça les rougés en â faites les
Rouger dans un petit bouillon vous
rajoutez de la crème fraîche si vous en
avez envie
euh il y a pas trop de il y a pas trop
d'arêtte non ben vous demandez à ce
qu'elle soit levée par par le poisson
demandz les filets voilà et sinon oui
moi j'aime les fruits de M aussi alors
vous allez dire c'est euh j'aime j'aime
faire les fruits de M dans les Paillas
en fait quand il m'arrive d'enfer euh
voilà c'est-à-dire des moules des
crevettes des choses comme ça mais mais
moi en fait je suis plus fan des
crustacés que je ne suis du poisson
voilà vous êtes un peu conservateur on
pourrait dire en matière de
cuisine je crois que je suis français
voyez ce que je veux dire franais donc
je je crois que oui je conservateur je
ne sais pas moi j'aime beaucoup découvir
que vous faisiez du couscous ou du
tajine donc vous avez desiration le
couscous c'est le plat préféré français
je crois c'est venu dans le PRI V
français ça voulait dire très hexagonal
et vous non parce que je crois qu'on a
la chance d'être un pays aussi qui a
accueilli voilà différentes vagues de
euh de population qui est lié à son
histoire d'ailleurs et et c'est plat les
gens mais c'est d'ailleurs toute la
noblesse de la cuisine c'est qu'à un
moment
euh le plébiscite fait que un plat qui
peut paraître exotique ou exogène rentre
dans le patrimoine culinaire français
voà France est grande c'est la seconde
surface maritime internationale euh on a
mout mout
qui ont elles-même des influences
chinoises indiennes créoles vous allez
chercher justement du côté de ces
cuisines là du côté de l'Asie de
l'Amérique du Sud alors à vrai je vais
vous dire non j'ai une de mes cousines
qui a épousé un médecin antiller je
crois que la dernière cuisine qui moi
m'a surpris le palais ça a été de manger
un cabri
euh fait au
curryé France on rest en France oui
d'accord mais c'était aussi encore une
influence qui peut se faire ailleurs sur
d'autres îles ou en guillane française
donc là oui ça a surpris mes papill
mais ouais on va dire que je suis un peu
pas chauvin mais donc la cuisine
japonaise la cuisine thaïlandaise toutes
ces cuisines qui sont un petit peu à la
mode alors moi j'ai un tropisme pour la
cuisine asiatique en général et j'ai un
vrai tropisme pour la cuisine libanaise
que j'adore les MZ entre autres sans
doute une des meilleures cuisines du
moyen-orientant
disait qu' mit pas tellement vous avez
l' d'être gourmand sur le papier mais
est-ce que vous êtes vraiment un un
mangeur est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
faire des kilomètres pour aller trouver
une recette pour aller trouver un bou
boui ou un grand restaurant parce que à
vous écouter vous mangez pas grandchose
dans la journée non alors ça vous êtes
en train de dévoiler une conversation
qu'on a eu tout à l'heure alors
effectivement je ne c'était du Off
Jean-Pierre je ne collationne pas je
prends pas de petit déjeuner le jeunne
intermittent très bien très c'est par
choix c'est un jeune intermitant non en
fait c'est une je crois que c'est une
très mauvaise habitude qui s'est
installée chez moi c'est-à-dire que je
ne prends pas de petit déjeuner bah pour
les nutritionnistes c'est une très bonne
habitude intermitt je ne déjeune pas
pardon vous ne déjeez pas non rarement
euh et en fait pas non et pourtant les
amis lorsque je vais chez eux a un ami
dernièrement là m'a dit dans les alpill
il vaut mieux t'avoir en photo qu'atable
parce que visiblement je dévorais bah
oui vous AZ pas mangé ni le matin ni à
midi donc le soir vous oui mais c'est
pas c'est pas tous les jours alors je
suis gourmand mais si et c'est pas bien
il faut pas suivre cet exemple si je
saute des repas c'est quelque chose qui
ne me qui ne me gêne pas d'accord mais
mais vous ne déjeunez jamais ça veut
dire que vous n'avez qu'un seul repas
quotidien ouais le le le soir oui
d'accord à une heure précise ou parce
qu'avec les horaires que vous devez
avoir le soir en fait c'est généralement
le soir comme je rentre très tard à la
maison je suis très présent en
circonscription bon un repas c'est un
peu ça va être et c'est pas du tout de
la caricature ça va être du saucisson de
taureau avec un morceau de pain un bout
de fromage le chèvre et d'accord et et
alors vous vous sentez en forme parce
que à nous décrire votre menu votre
votre quotidien c'est pas forcément très
équilibré pas de carence ou vous parce
en fait le matin moi je me fais un
cocktail de fruits donc je mélange plein
de fruits j'imagine qu'ils font le
boulot enfin j'ose croire qu'ils font le
boulot euh donc ça vous donne des
vitamines pour toutes les journées
j'imagine oui mais après je suis
quelqu'un qui suit qui suit très très
laborieux très concentré et et
j'ai j'ai toujours en fait je je ne
cours pas après le temps mais j'ai
toujours ce souci d'être présent et
d'être là et je me dis c'est souvent la
mine en fait de mes collaborateurs c'est
soit l'un ou l'autre qui m'accompagne en
circonscription quand je vois par
exemple qu'à l'heure du
déjeuner il voit qu'on enclenche sur une
autre série alors maintenant je prends
conscience qu'il faut qu'il prenne une
heure pour pour déjeuner parce que c'est
eux dans leurs habitudes et puis qu'il
les y on droit mais euh à chaque fois je
leur dis Moon écoutez allez où vous
voulez on se retrouve dans une heure moi
entre-etemps je fais ça mais parce que
moi dans ma tête comme ça naturellement
ça vient pas de me dire à MIDH ou 13h il
faut s'arrêter pour déjeuner ou à 19h ou
20h il faut rentrer dans un restaurant
pour et dans les circonscriptions n'est
pas toujours attendu il y a pas toujours
quelque chose à gréignoté surtout en
Provence ou très
hospitaliisir touourselose per peut-être
de tenir le coup maintenant je crois que
les gens ont compris comment je
fonctionnais c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
pris l'habitude en me suivant sur les
réseaux sociaux de voir ce rythme un peu
effrainé qui est le mien d'aller d'un
événement à l'autre et donc au départ il
ne comprenaiit pas que je ne reste pas
donc excepé une une invitation formelle
dans ce cas je le reste je resterai mais
la semaine dernière par exemple j'étais
à une manifestation
de associative de rapatriés et de Archy
qui organisait un grand couscous bon là
j'ai compris qu'au bout d'un an et demi
ils avaient compris que je ne resterai
pas à table mais en revanche je suis
reparti avec deux plats plein de
couscous de la de la manifestation et
d'ailleurs la que vous avez congelé
peut-être la je c'était à midi comme
j'ai passé la journée sur le terrain la
voiture embomumée le couscous qui était
délicieux ouais oui parce que on peut se
vexer aussi quand on refuse
souvent maintenantant comme je vous
explique ils comprennent que je comme je
veux pouvoir répondre au au rendez-vous
d'accord ils se Formalis pas ils ont
compris la fréquence en fait et c'est
pas comme si je passais en coup de vent
généralement je reste une ou de heures à
chaque événement je me montre pas un
quart d'heure pour serrer des mains et
partir parce que j'aime discuter et
qu'on me tienne au courant de ce qui se
passe mais maintenant ils comprennent
que j'ai pas forcément la l'après-midi à
et ça m'est encore arrivé à arle bah
dimanche dernier où une association
traditionnelle m'a invité euh m'a invité
parce qu'il faisait leur déjeuner et moi
j'avais bien précisé sur messenger je
suis ravi de votre invitation mais je
viendrai partager un un sodat avec vous
et après je me sauverai d'accord une
question est-ce que le rassemblement
national défend le le localisme dans
dans sa politique est-ce que vous à
votre niveau vous faites aussi vous
consommez toujours local vous faites
attention à
çaorsbimef depuis que je suis élu j'ai
mis je mets un point d'honneur à
quasiment tout acheter dans ma
circonscription euh que ce soit la
viande que ce soit les légumes ou les
produits préparés vient de la
circonsption type fromage saucisson ce
genre de choses alors je les achète si
moi je là je viens de voir que j'avais
un stock de miel invraisemblable parce
qu'on fait beaucoup de miel dans la
crero et dans les Alpines notamment et
une partie de la Camargue euh maintenant
j'ai quand même tendance à mais c'est
bien parce que j'imagine que sans
prétention je j'assure la promotion du
territoire par exemple tous les cadeaux
que je fais pour Noël ou ou pour les les
anniversaires maintenant sont j'allais
dire alimentaires je n'offre que des
paniers donc je vais acheter mon petit
panier de mon côté et je le remplis
d'huile d'olive de de ma
circonscription de fromage qui se garde
de miel de vin parce qu'on fait aussi en
liignore beaucoup de Meur cadeau pour
jean-pierreou mais il faut dire que
c'est un pays de cocagne aussi hein
c'est vrai qu'à porté de main vous avez
de l'huile d'olive du trs bon vin des
fruits des amandes des légumes toute
saison les meilleures tomates les
meilleures courgettes les meilleures
aubergines ou oui on a il y a une vraie
tradition agricole poisson comme l'a dit
Brigit la viande il y a pas besoin
d'aller ailleurs que et c'est vrai que
pour le poisson on a la chance d'avoir
encore quelques pêur au Sainte-Marie de
la mer mais c'est vrai que c'est un pays
une terre bénie des dieux hein que ce
soit les alpis la Camargue la crro la
montagnett qui sont sur mon territoire
euh moi je suis je vais vous dire pour
moi c'est pas de la flag gornerie je
suis l'autre un matin comme ça il y a
pas très longtemps c'éit avant les fêtes
je suis allé rabattre du bétail bah
justement des taureaux avec des
manadiers à cheval et les les gars vous
tapent dans le dos vous tutoi vous
rouoit même et je me suis senti en
traversant et en et en galopant et en
étant avec eux dans ces paysages de
camargu je me suis senti c'est rare dans
la vie hein je me suis senti aligné à ma
place euh et et est chanceux voir
privilégié euh parce que la beauté des
paysagestion à un moment je ne sais plus
je levais la tête ENF j' essayais de
discipliner un petit peu le cheval Camar
qu'on m'avait confié parce qu'il était
pas à attendre avec moi et j'ai levé la
tête et là il y avait un vol de flamand
rose dans ce ciel gris le soleil
commençait à se lever et je me suis dit
mais tu as une chance folle en fait tu
mais cette chance il faut se montrer
digne parce que si les gens sont
accueillants ils vous attendent et c'est
tout à fait normal euh au tournant voilà
c'est pour ça que vous êtes très présent
dans votre circonscription c'est pour ça
que vous nous avez demandé de la
gardienne de de taureau un plat
politiquement peut-être correct avec du
on on va y revenir mais surtout avec un
vin rouge aussi qui est du coin c'est le
domaine attilon donc là évidemment c'est
région Provence en appelle appellation
IGP pays des bouches du rô terre de
camarg un terroir argile au calcaire et
limonneux un vin de couleur rouge
évidemment un sépage pin noir c'est un
mésim 2020 et il a des d'arôme de ceris
de framboise une finale assez épicée
c'est un vin qui est donc un peu
puissant qui se marie très bien avec la
la gardiane c'est un vin que vous
connaissez bien parce que
vous c'est un vin que je connaissais que
je connaissais déjà avant d'être élu
député et puis c'est un vin que j'ai
redécouvert euh alors là vous allez dire
que je suis vraiment pas du tout
politiquement correct VO très
conservateur que j'ai redécouvert dans
un déjeuner de chasseur dans lequel
j'étais invité après chasseur Corina ça
commence après une chasse
et j'avais décrété comme d'habitude que
je ne boiris pas en journée bon
finalement ils m'ont convaincu là j'ai
vraiment vu que ce serait mal vu de pas
partager le verre de l'amitié et
finalement je suis reparti avec une
caisse de domaine de la Tyon et c'est un
vin que j'apprécie énormément et
j'aimerais redire qu'on a une vraie
tradition de vin en camarg dans les
alpis aussi alors chacun a sa typicité
et que c'est va vraiment le mérite
d'être d'être connu et reconnu parce que
nos vignerons ont fait un vrai travail
sur la qualité des vins sur les sur les
20 dernières années où maintenant il
n'est pas rare de voir des vins qui sont
primés dans des concours agricoles ou
des concours généraux euh qui plusit des
vins de des bouches du rô et et de
camarg et des alpill et je trouve que le
travail que que nos viticulteurs font
est quelque chose de de magnifique avec
avec la vigne parce que c'est ce que
l'on a dans dans un verre alors c'est le
fruit de leur travail mais c'est aussi
ce que la terre les
éléments aussi par moment l'eau salé
veut bien veut bien vous donner à
extraire et c'est tout ce terroir qu'on
retrouve effectivement dans ce dans ce
vin bon vous m'avez l'airême de bien
vous y connaître on va voir si vous êtes
incollable c'est le
quiz amateur de Cora et de gardian nous
savez que dans le taureau tout est bon y
compris la queue bien sûr et même même
les parties intimes pas de tabou en
cuisine pourriez-vous me dire si ces
affirmations sont vraies ou fausses pour
désigner donc ces parti comestible des
animaux les cuisiniers les chefs
n'emploient jamais le mot testicule vrai
ou faux je dirais faux non vrai
visiblement visiblement c'est tabout ou
alors ça peut amener à des à des petites
comparaisons douteuses on parle plutôt
d'animel d'amourette ou de reunnon dans
le cas des taureaux noirs on parle de
truff pour les qualifier vrai ou faux
faux vrai ouais ou
dans les années 80 la confrerie des
joyeuses fondée notamment par le Chef
Alain Chapel célèbre la cuisine des
rogons de coqu joyeux c'est aussi un
autre nom pour désigner donc les
animeles d'accord alors est-ce que c'est
vrai que ça célébrait la cuisine des
rognons de
coqu quit à avoir tout faux je le crois
pas c'est faux c'était des rognons
blancs de moutons bah là vous avez là
vous avez bon enfin la légende dit que
l'épouse du roi Louis XIV préparé des
recettes de boucher à laarine au Rogon
de coque pour doper ses performances
sexuelles vrai ou faux alors ça
m'étonnerait puisque les bouchets à Laar
reine sont arrivés avec Marie les insca
l'épouse de Louis XV alors je sais pas
si le terme bouch à la reine est juste
et ben bravo parce que c'est
effectivement le l'épouse du roi Louis
XV qui faisait des bouchers à la reine
avec des rognons de coqu pour doper les
performances sexuelles du monarque bravo
bravo 2è quiz alors vous avez sans doute
vu une gorgée d'Orangina un soda dont la
fabrication c'est longtemps fait à
vitrol sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sont vraies ou fausses ah
c'est un Piednoir Jean-Claude beton qui
fonde Orangina dans la ville de boufaric
en Algérie en 1951 vrai bravo vous
deviez être au courant mais dans
l'Orangina il n'y a que de l'eau
gazéifiée du jus d'orange et de la pulpe
d'orange je dirais vrai alors faux jus
de citron pamplemousse et mandarine
d'accord tout ça dans le la bouteille
d'Orangina l'alliage euh en 1972 un clip
célèbre slogan d'Orangina il faut
renverser la bouteille d'Orangina pour
bien mélanger la pulpe d'orange est-ce
que c'est vrai ou est-ce que c'est faux
mais c'est pas secou moi ce queou moi
oui c'est ça donc c'était faux il faut
secouer la bouteille d'Orin pas la
remuer ouais euh dès la marque n'a
jamais pu être lancée aux États-Unis à
cause de la résistance de Coca-Cola il
me semble alors non on en trouve et ça a
été lancé en 1983 malgré
Coca-Cola de Coca-Cola donc vous voyez
euh secouez-moi secouz-moi on connait
tous ce clip quand on est Meur ou
voilàcén oui mais même je crois que le
slogan ils l'ont toujours ils l'ont fait
perdurer il y a il y a encore pas
beaucoup oui mais parce qu'il y a de la
pulpe dans le talent de cette marque le
talent de cette marque ça a été aussi de
de de renverser la table par l'image en
s'adjoignant aussi le talent de grands
réalisateurs ouais et puis c'est la
forme de cette bouteille aussi toute
ronde qui qui interp changé d'ailleurs
pas changé depuis depuis toujours alors
vous savez que c'est souvent autour de
la table que ce nous les meilleures
histoires que se font parfois les deals
politiques et donc se fait la la petite
et la grande Histoire et c'est la breève
de
comptoir alors Emmanuel Tach laabachon
vous a demander de vous souvenir
peut-être d'une anecdote politique
autour d'un d'un repas est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en raconter une oui alors
écoutez il y a pas très longtemps
c'était l'été dernier j'étais donc à
Tarascon qui est une des principales
villes de ma circonscription il y avait
un un spectacle alors j'ai découvert
l'homme un spectacle de Patrick
Sébastien mais à grande échelle et le
maire de Tarascon avait fait une table
avec avec l'ensemble des des élus alors
vous évz bien qu'il y a des tendances
politiques qui sont qui sont qui sont
différentes moi j'ai j'avais Monsieur le
Maire m'avait fait l'honneur de me
mettre à sa droite en face de moi
j'avais Patrick de Carolis le le maire
d'Arle ainsi que d'autres élus qui
étaient là et bon Patrick Sébastien fait
son show l'atmosphère se euh voilà tout
le monde commence à tourner les
serviettes voilà et à un moment et j'ai
trouvé ça très drôle parce que moi j'ai
voulu que mon mandat se place sous le
signe de la concorde entre les uns et
les autres je ne veux pas de
d'affrontement entre mes mères et moi
euh parce qu'on doit servir notre
territoire chacun a sa façon mais de
façon commune et à un moment l'animateur
donc Patrick Sébastien dit euh lance à
la
cantonnade euh faites un bisou eu faites
un bisou à à votre voisin alors là vous
êtes déçu mais il y a pas de deal mais
tout le monde j'allais dire s claqué la
bise en étant surpris mais tell
tellement pris dans l'ambiance que s
embrassé certaines rigidités se sont
assoupli et j'ai trouvé ça je me je me
suis dit que c'était une belle image en
fait ça pouvait paraître trivial
euh et et en fait c'était improbable moi
lorsque j'ai été élu qui a cette cette
bonne entented vous pensez que vous en
tant que RN il y allit avoir beaucoup
d'animosité pas vraiment en fait je
pensais que comme j'allais dire nouveau
de la bande euh nouveauté dans le
paysage dans le paysage politique il y
avait donc des attentes et peut-être
peut-être certaines inquiétudes je ne
sais pas et je sais que beaucoup
disaient des gentillesses derrière mon
dos bon bref sans me connaître et je me
suis dit là voilà on est quasiment à un
an et demi du mandat
euh me parlant à moi-même et je me suis
dit si tu as réussi ça c'est-à-dire
qu'on est capable de tout se mettre
autour d'une table euh il y a pas
d'acrimonie je ne mêle pas de leurs
histoires même si je suis parfaitement
au courant de tout ce qu' se passe je ne
juge pas leur leur réflexion ni leur
réalisation je me l'interdis parce que
je respecte trop leur travail et je me
suis dit voilà on peut arriver bien que
les étiquettes ne soient pas les mêmes à
un moment arrivver non pas faut pas
délirer sur l'état de grâce mais à un
instant de respect mutuel où chacun
quand on travaille sérieusement euh est
détendu avec l'autre dépose les armes et
ce moment-l j'allais dire de fête et de
liè avec avec cet animateur qui dit
faites un bisou moi j'ai été surpris de
voir le maire de Tarascon me faire un
bisou mais j'ai été surpris de devoir en
rendre un voilà mais j'ai finalement je
me je me suis dit est-ce que c'est pas
non plus parce qu'on est observé par nos
concitoyens et je me suis je me suis dit
est-ce que c'est pas est-ce que c'est
pas non plus donneré un signe que les
choses insitu peuvent se passer
agréablement et qu'on n pas obligé de
s'écharper alors on va pass pass à la
galette des rois parce qu'on est en
plein mois de janvier sans aucune
transition c'est une tradition bien
française là on aurait pu faire une
petite transition que l'on déguste donc
maintenant la traditionnelle est à la
fragipane mais il existe bon nombre de
variantes et c'est le dessous des
plats alors la monarchie est bien
révolue mais les Français restent
attachés à la couronne pour devenir roi
ou reine et bien il faut avant tout
tomber sur la fève loger dans la galette
pour les boulang le r après Noël car les
Français en raol Marco Pomier et Marion
Devel c'est la star du mois de janvier
elle est partout la galette des rois son
succès est incontestable c'est bon la
galette c'est une tradition familiale
depuis un certain nombre d'années vous
étiez pas encore
jeune j'avais jeunes petites
collection dans cette boulangerie
parisienne on en produit entre 80 et 100
par jour 2000 sur le mois de janvier ici
le roi de la galette c'est lui Vincent
salure et il y en a pour tous les coups
la spécialité chez nous c'est la galette
100 % pistache on prend la pistache
moitié de Turquie moitié d'Iran on fait
un mélange et on fait également la la
pomme qui reste assez classique mais il
ne faut pas s'y tromper la plus
populaire reste la galette franipane
tout se joue au gram près alors ne
comptez pas sur notre chef pâtissier
pour vous révéler les quantités exactes
c'est un secret bien gardé ça c'est une
recette qui qui date d' a 17 ans c'est
mon maître d'apprentissage s'appelait
Régis scolin il m'a transmis son
savoir-faire 3 jours c'est le temps
qu'il faudra à Vincent salure et ses
équipes pour confectionner cette
pâtisserie première étape la pâte
feuilletée sa fabrication est longue
pétrir la pâte 24 heures de repos au
frigo avant d'incorporer le beurre puis
retour au frais pendant 24 heur à
nouveau plus on laisse dans le frigo
plus il y aura il y aura de de l'arôme
en fait la pâte va fermenter après la
mise en disque l'heure de garnir la
galette avec la fameuse frangipanne du
sucre encore du beurre des œufs et de la
poudre d'amande venue tout droit de
Californie Californie pourquoi parce
qu'elle est très riche en en gras en
fait et ce qui donne le goût c'est ce
qui donne le goût et la touche du chef
du R pâtissier sans oublier cette jolie
fève en forme de macaron encore une
heure de cuisson au four au moins et ça
y est notre prête reste un hi pour
beaucoup d'entre vous le prix 5 € la
part individuelle dans cette boulangerie
30 € pour 6 personnes c'est pour ça que
les gens ils disent ah mais les galettes
en boulangerie c'est cher et tout mais
en fait nous on met on met 3 jours pour
faire la pâte en boulangerie on aura une
qualité de matière premières beaucoup
plus qualitative nous on achète des
producteurs directement un savoir-faire
coûteux aux enjeux important pour
Vincent salure au mois de janvier la
galette des rois c'est 50 % de son
chiffre d'affaires près de 10 % sur
l'ensemble de l'année
Emmanuel Tach de la page est-ce que vous
aussi vous faites partie de tous ces
Français qui sont fans de la galette oui
alors comme j'ai pu vous le dire
précédemment moi je fais partie de cette
catégorie de personne qui achète pendant
la pode de l'épiphanie des galettes des
roi à la frangipane et qu' les mettent
au congélateur pour en avoir pas toute
l'année parce que mais pour en avoir
sous la main ouais vous faites des pars
comme ça et puis vous les mettez dans
votre congélateur ouais ouais ouais
c'est vrai et vous la cuisinez pas non
je l'ai déjà fait une fois d'accord fe
pardon pas la pâte feuilleté alors non
la pâte feuilleté je l'avais acheté
toute faite parce des heures et des
heures ouais j'adore ça vous adorez ça
mais dans le sud c'est pas la
traditionnelle à frangipan c'est pas la
couronne des rois qu'on retrouve non
alors on a la couronne des rois c'est
une brioche la couronne des rois et dans
ma partie du Sud à moi et c'est très
joli je trouve ce nom on on appelle C
cette brioche cette couronne des rois un
royaume un royaume ouais et alors vous
vous préférez quand même la
traditionnelle franipan alors la
franipan j'allais dire pour le goûter
parce que ça m'arrive de grignoter le
dimanche quand je suis à la maison quand
même quand même et puis le royaume donc
la brioche j'aime bien moi je suis
quelqu'un d'assez régressif quand même
j'ai des réflexes d'enfant j'aime bien
la la tromper dans le lait ah c'est le
petit déjeuner du dimanche alors là mais
est-ce que en à Marseille il y a une
guerre des galettes il y a la galette et
la brioche ou votre royaume là qui se
parce qu'à Paris on voit pas de brioche
du Sud non mais c'est très c'est très
typique c'est très c'est très j'allais
dire je pense qu'on doit trou àtir de la
drô provenale jusqu'à jusqu'à Nice on
doit balayer la la région en passant par
chez moi euh mais nonous il y a pas de
guerre vous trouvez à part égal des
royaumes donc des couronnes de Noël et
des galettes des galettes et alors on
voit de plus en plus de variantes
aujourd'hui il en a au chocolat là il y
en avait dans le sujet à la pistache au
fruits rougge enfin vous vous aimez
aussi ces variantes ou vous vous êtes
plutôt attachéir je vais reprendre le
terme que vous avez employé tout à
l'heure je suis assez conservateur et
traditionnel j'en ai un petit peu marre
qu'on euh qu'on change l'origine des
recettes euh et puis alors peut-être que
c'est c'est c'est une part d'enfance qui
veut pas qui veut pas partir mais je
trouve dommage qu'on qu'on réinvente une
recette qui je crois existe depuis le
Moyen-âge bon parce que c'est pas le
progrès de faire avancer une recette de
la retravailler der la pistage je sais
pas si c'est du progrès pas dans le
cadre de la de la science ça vous plaît
pas alors cela dit il y en a qui
redoutent alors là on a vu chocolat
pomme aussi il y a des des pâtissiers
comme Pierre Herm qui déclinent des
gâteaux en galette comme l'ispaon mais
les puristes comme vous les
conservateurs ont une trouille
épouvantable c'est qu'on on est des gens
qui la revisitent sous forme de pavé
sous forme de de carré parce qu'on a
bien vu que charttin transformé les les
Paris Brest les éclairs est-ce que ça
vous pensez que ça peut arriver un jour
ou qu'elle résistera à ces petites je
pense que ça ça résistera et ça
n'empêche pas l'originalité ou ou
l'interprétation mais je trouve que
c'est tellement beau le symbole de euh
de cette galette alors il y a l'aspect
on peut dire l'aspect spirituel et ce
qu'elle doit fêter mais c'est tellement
joli ce je crois que c'est censé c'est
c'est une une tradition romaine qui est
censée représenter un soleil et
l'allongement des jours alors on dit que
on on accolle cela maintenant cette
tradition roim mage mais je trouve aussi
que la symbolique est très belle
finalement si on veut bien s'attarder
dessus de ce voilà de de cette base à
préparation de beaucoup de beurre et de
et d'amande qui est censé représenter le
soleil je trouve que c'est quand même
très joli après ça n'empêche pas
oui l'interprétation pourquoi pas enfin
moi je leur souhaite beaucoup de succès
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous trouvez
qu'elle est cher comme beaucoup de
Français alors en même temps on a
entendu cet artisan qui disait la
matières premières et chères ça prend du
temps 3 jours pour la fabriquer il y a
un savoir-faire n'oublions pas que nos
commerçants ont pris notamment les
boulangers pâtissiers en plein visage
l'augmentation de l'électricité qu'on a
pas voulu baisser c'est la fin d'échec
et du du quoi qu'il en coûte il y a un
savoir-faire une main d'œuvre je
comprends que je comprends que ça puisse
surprendre choquer j'espère que les gens
qui ont les moins moyen de payer 30 €
une galette alors chez moi je crois que
c'est plus en moyen de 20 € euh le fond
ne serait-ce que pour
soutenir boulang vous vous seriez pour
la politique du chèque il faudrait
continuer àion crois non mais je crois
que si déjà on pouvait leur permettre de
payer leur factures et si on ne les
assommait pas et qu'ils ne soi pas
obligés d'éteindre parce que il faut
imaginer un boulanger s'il est un four
c'est des heures et des heures à mettre
en chauffe donc ça veut dire des heures
et des heures à tirer sur sur sur les
réseaux électriques si déjà la France
revenait à la raison concernant les prix
de l'électricité euh ça pourrait ça
pourrait être une piste après moi je
n'ai pas de jugement sur euh bah ceux
d'entre nous qui n'ont pas d'autre choix
que de se tourner vers le par vers le
traditionnel B tout le monde a quand
même le droit de de tirer les rois de
fêter la tradition quel que soit ses
moyens donc oui moi je comprends qu'on
arrive dans certaines villes à à des
prix qui frôent qui tutoi voir qui
dépasse les 30 parce qu'il y a la main
d'œuvre le monsieur l'a dire il y a
plusieurs jours de préparation pour la
pâte feuilletée donc j'allais dire oui
mais c'est le prix d'un travail bien
fait est-ce que je m'en réjouis je crois
pas mais je crois qu'il faut il faut
dans la mesure du possible les soutenir
oui allez on va retourner chez vous en
camarg où on va parler maintenant du riz
mais cet aliment est en grande partie
importé d'ind de Thaïlande ou du Vietnam
alors pourquoi on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le
plat
alors Brigitte le français aime de plus
en plus le riz il en mange près de 6 kg
par an alors ce qui n'est rien ridicule
même par rapport au birman le champion
du monde qui lui en consomme 170 kg par
an essentiellement le riz de nos
assiettes est orté d'Asie le reste
environ un tiers vient de la Camargue et
du delta du rô où est produit un riz IGP
de qualité reportage les pied dans l'eau
de Clément Perou tourné en automne
dernier au moment de la
récolte
on dit du riz qu'il pousse les pieds
dans l'eau et la tête au soleil en
France sa terre d'adoption était toute
trouvée la Camargue alain girud est
résiculteur dans ce coin du Sud si
singulier où pousse 95 % du riz français
pour faire pousser du riz il faut des
sols plats donc la Camargue vu que c'est
un territoire qui est assees plat c'est
beaucoup plus facile à niveler que si on
voulait faire du riz à montagne ou alors
les planches comme on voit beaucoup en
Asie
ensuite nous avons les deux bras du rond
qui alimentent en eau douce qui a un
grand volume d'eau qui arrive parce que
le riz nécessite dans sa culture
beaucoup
d'eau les champs sont mis en eau au
printemps pour 150 jours puis assécher
quelques semaines avant la récolte
autonnale qui a lieu ce jour-là sur
cette parcelle le riz se ramasse avec
une moissonneuse batteuse équipée de
chenilles pour avancer dans la terre
humide les plantes sont comme peignées
par la machine elle en extrait des
grains encore recouverts par leur
enveloppe naturelle appelé la balle
voilà ça c'est ce que ramasse le
résiculteur après c'est le risier qui va
faire les opérations pour le pour le
blanch cette année la récolte est bonne
les fortes chaleurs que connaît la
France sont favorables à la fécondation
du riz la filière a le potentiel pour se
développer aujourd'hui on produit à peu
près 13000 hectares de riz ce qui fait à
peu près 70000 tonne de riz qui couvre à
peine 20 % de nos besoins en France
l'idée ce serait quand même de revenir à
une souveraineté alimentaire pour pour
la ferme France ce serait très
[Musique]
intéressant plus que la quantité le riz
made in France se distingue par sa
qualité au Sainte-Marie de la mer le
chef Roger Merlin nous donne sa recette
du risotto version
camarg échalotte a le riz dedans
ça c'est le riz spécial pour
risotto
rond on va attendre que le vin soit
complètement absorbé pour après mettre
le
bouillon du romarin du thyint plein
d'herbes dedans toutes les herbes que
j'ai et toutes mes toutes mes épluchures
de légumes au lieu de les jeter je fais
un
bouillon voilà là j'en mets une ou deux
cuillères je vais
remuer en fin de cuisson le chef ajoute
du parmesan et de la crème de riz ce
risoto de la terre est accompagné de
légumes croquants de saison saucisse de
taureau fumé carpachciio et chorizo de
taureau on est vraiment dans l'identité
du terroir de de camarg avec des
produits simples des recettes simples
blanc noir rouge complet une grande
diversité de riz est produite en
Camar alors on l'a dit he ça le RIC
àarget fournit 30 % de la consommation
française à peine les risiculteurs
disent qu'ils peuvent encore faire du
riz en plus grande quantité pourquoi on
essaie pas de développer cette culture
dans ce delta et en camarg il y a des
rétisences des résistances des obstacles
non je crois qu'ils essaient
profondément de de les développer après
on est aussi sur on est confronté aussi
à à une typicité de territoire et les
exploitations si elles peuvent être
extensibles encore faut-il trouver et
pouvoir acheter les terres disponibles à
la culture pour pouvoir AUG augmenter
cette cette production mais je sais
qu'ils y travaillent énormément il y a
pas des questions de protection aussi de
la biodiversité de la camarg il y a pas
duel entre la camarg et le riz non il y
a pas un duel enfin la camarg c'est un
parc naturel régional moi je me suis
battu et
notamment avec l'alerte des producteurs
de riz mais aussi de torocamarg et les
éleveurs de chevaux pour qu'on ait pas
le label parc national ça aurait été
dramatique pour le territoire donc il y
a effectivement une impréation entre euh
j'allais dire deux visions de l'écologie
et du développement du territoire
c'est-à-dire que euh la camarque
n'oublions pas c'est comme la vénée hein
c'est une création entièrement humaine
euh donc les chantres de l'écologie
oublient au passage que c'est l'homme
qui a décidé de créer une interaction
entre des éléments tels l'eau douce
l'eau de mer et et la terre qui est
particulière chez nous euh tout ça tout
ça est le fruit de la main de l'homme
mais je sais qu'il travaille
actuellement à à augmenter cette filière
là euh je crois parce que moi j'avais
insisté l'an passé j'avais été un petit
peu déçu au salon de l'agriculture de
voir que la Camargue était très peu
représenté finalement et euh et il
pourrait y avoir une souveraineté
alimentaire dans le dans le riz par
exemple parce qu'on en importe près de
80 % 70 % non je pense pas qu'on puisse
avoir de de souveraineté mais augmenter
de 10 à 20 % pour moi ce serait pas
serait pas serait pas lunaire serait pas
de l'ordre de de l'imagination mais
encore faut-il que
euh on puisse je tout à l'heure je je
captais je je parlais de la captation de
terrain et la possibilité de s'agrandir
ça devient de plus en plus compliqué moi
je sais que sur mon territoire j'ai été
alerté sur notamment les successions en
domaine agricole qui vont parcelé parce
que les héritiers ne vont pas pouvoir
garder chez moi son très grand domaine
et les héritiers qui certains ne sont
pas agriculteurs n'ont pas vocation à à
garder cette terre qui est quand même
très particulière et qui coûte très cher
et que ça ça peut aussi être la course
de celui qui en a le plus sous le pied
peut capter ces terrain là donc pour
l'instant dire qu' il y a des étrangers
qui pourraient comme on achète des vins
des des vins de ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on a de plus en plus de
personn on a de plus en plus de
personnes qui sont étrangèr à notre
territoire qui rachète des parcelles
entières des hectares entiers et pas des
petites quantités d'hectares pour
souvent si fixé en terme de résidence
secondaire qui ne travaillent pas cette
terre camargise qui est particul
et qui à terme pourrait mener sur sur
une partie de de nos territoires à la
mort de nos paysages tel que nous nous
les connaissons nos paysages sont des
paysages qui sont certes sauvages mais
ils sont pas sauvages comme ça pour
faire joli ils sont sauvages parce que
ce sont les sabots des taureaux qui les
travaillent parce que ce sont les sabots
des chevaux qui les travaillent par son
sonilleurs donc rés Rion pour ne pas qu'
disparaisse mais je pense qu'à terme on
on va on on va en avoir besoin d'une
véritable on a été interrogé par le
ministère de la transition écologique
entre autres l'année dernière sur
spécifiquement la gestion de l'eau et et
le devenir de la Camargue lorsqu'on voit
certaines projections à 100 ans de la
Camargue
euh si on ne se dépêche pas de faire
quelques chose une bonne partie sera
sous
l'eau donc il est temps de se bouger
parce que 100 temps c'est demain moi je
ne serai plus là et plus personne n'aura
souvenir de ENF voilà je mais mais mais
le temps que je suis là et le le temps
que je suis à ma place et le temps que
les uns et les autres acteurs publics
sont à leur place je crois qu'il est
grand temps de cesser de se payer de
déclaration et vraiment travailler sur
quel
est que se fixe-t-on à 100 ans pour ce
territoire pour qu'on puisse le Léguer
moi j'allais j'ai aucune démarche
égoïste je n'ai pas d'enfant à titre
personnel donc je ce ne sera pas ma
continuité qui verra ces paysages mais
mais cette beauté là sa le territoire en
fait oui on se bat en plus pour qu'elle
soit inscrite à l'Unesco et et on
aimerait que cette reconnaissance
permettre justement une une protection
mais protection ça veut dire aussi des
moyens financiers pour pour travailler
notamment sur le trait de côte et l'eau
et en même temps le paradoxe Brigit
c'est qu'effectivement le réchauffement
climatique est favorable à la production
du riz puisquil favorise sa fécondation
dans un même tempsaleur on Perm de
C mais en même temps si les EAU montent
et puis l'eau dou permet aussi de de
protéger cet écosystème si les eau et
les eau qui montent ce sont des EAU
salées de fait le pompage pour avoir de
l'eau dou c'est très compliqué parce
qu'il faut aussi avoir le ressource la
ressource en eau douce et que je ne veux
pas dire de bêtises mais il y a 2 ans la
situation était extrêmement caniculaire
et un manadier m'a dit que deux de ces
bêtes deux de ces taureaux étaient morts
parce que l'eau qui remontait du sol
dans les flaques naturel était
principalement salé et que les bêtes
n'avaient pas supporté allez on va
passer au dessert puisquon a on a fini
le plat et c'est le péché mignon
oui avec un dessert totem de la botte le
tir Missou qui serait figurez-vous le
deuxième mot italien le plus utilisé
dans le monde tir Missou Brigitte
signifie littéralement redonne-moi des
forces donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
qu'il y ait beaucoup de café pour que on
soit réveillé vous avez aussi des
racines italiennes pour aimer le tiram
Missou alors je n'ai pas de racine
italienne je suis vice-président du
groupe France Italie toutefois j'ai une
passion pour l'Italie que je ne
m'explique pas si alors peut-être si
parce qu'on y mange bien les italien
j'ai une passion culturelle j'ai une
passion pour la langue j'aime parler
italien j'aime lire les informations en
italien j'aime les regarder en italien
j'aime conserver les conversations j'ai
vécu en Italie à vrai dire et j'ai une
une passion pour ce pour ce pays et en
fait le tiramisou qui est une recette
lombarde d'Italie du Nord ça veut dire
littéralement tire-moi vers le haut
voilà je je crois que c'est plutôt né à
Trévise le tiram Missou il peut y avoir
après voà après il y a toujours des
paternités fait moi lorsque je vivais en
Italie du Nord j'ai d'abord vécu à Milan
puis après à Venise euh j'avais une
pasticcherie il a une une pâtisserie à
côté de la maison qui faisait un tiram
Missou à ce Dané et en fait moi qui ne
mangeais jamais de sucre j'ai découvert
le goût du sucre grâce à ce dessert et
vous avez vous le préparez aussi chez
vous vous AZ une bonne recette très
simple c'est assez facile à faire et
alors là je je reviens aussi mais c'est
le traditionnel le le cons conservateur
aussi oui parce que je n'ai rien contre
nos amis biscuit le le les boudoirs les
biscuits à la cuillère ah çaardi oui les
boudoir ah oui moi je préfère pavisini
les plus plats comme ça mais il y a une
corerelle il y a une bagarre en Italie
là-dessus oui pour moi c'est boudoir
voilà biscuit à la cuireez pour nous
dire ce que vous rappelle V classique
parce que je n'ai rien contre mes mes
collèg nordist mais ou nos amis belges
mais les tiram misso spculos pour moi
c'est juste une trahison bah ouais je
trouve que c'est très on en trouve aussi
au fruits rouges quand c'est la saison
avec des des fraises on revisite les
tyram revisite mais c'est vrai que
traditionnel et mais en plus je trouve
que ça fait partie des est-ce que c'est
le mascarpone est-ce que Tron la
tendreté de la chose on a l'impression
de croquer dans un nuage en fait c'est
ça qui est assez assez plaisant alors
celui-ci est bon mais je trouve qu'il
manque toujours et justement vous disz
tirmi vers l'ut manque du café il est
pas assez fort c'est pas ce amisou qui
va vraiment n r manque de café et il
manque certainement aussi un petit peu
d'amaret un peu d'alcool alors on finit
toujours cette émission en musique on va
écouter celle que vous avez
[Musique]
choisi alors la musique continue c'est
une musique d'Endel c'est ça oui voilà
pourquoi vous l'avez choisi en fait
c'est le largot de
mais là c'est l'introduction il est
beaucoup plus beau chanter lorsque
l'alto va va tout en haut on dirait
qu'il qu'il supplie le ciel en fait
c'est le largot de de xerè du roi perse
xerè alors c'est un roi imaginaire de
Hendel qui ombramail fou c'est une
déclaration d'amour d'un d'un roi de la
guerre à un
platane et qui lui dit finalement je
suis tellement bien sous tes frondaisons
je n'ai plus à affronter l'injustice des
hommes et celle du glève euh protège-moi
d'accord et et les aigus qui sont la
bartolie Cécilia Bartoli les chante très
bien moi il y a quelque chose qui me qui
me qui me perce le cœur la première fois
que je l'ai entendu c'était au théâre
des Champs-Élysées interprété
par le chanteur d'opéra Andreas stols
allemand et les larmes ont coulé je sais
queouticul j'ai j'ai eu l'impression
d'entendre la voix des anges en fait
c'était quelque chose de qui vous et
quand il est chanté cette
are il tire enfin moi ça me transpersce
le cœur mais j'allais dire pas de
tristesse HE sont des larmes de bonheur
à chaque fois ça me sur cette touche là
alors si vous le voulez bien merci
d'avoir partagé ce déjeuner avec nous
merci à chez Françoise qui nous
accompagne évidemment toujours dans
cette émission merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi et puis rendez-vous bien sûr
la semaine prochaine sur LCP pour un
nouveau politique à
table
[Musique]